direct les collectivés locales sont à
loos ya plus de gras il ya plus de chair
il faut pas db c'est plus moi je plaide
pour un maintien des dotations et une
pause dans les réformes administratives
est un sujet inquiète au coeur de la
campagne des sénatoriales 1 qui auront
lieu dans deux semaines est ce que selon
vous la vague macron s'arrêtera aux
portes du sénat
mais moi je fais pas de pronostics je
suis pas pronostiqueur politique
ce que je sais aujourd'hui c'est que le
gouvernement macron propose pour les
collectivités territoriales suppression
de la taxe d'habitation sans qu'on sache
ce qu'ils valent à compenser fin des
contrats et des baisses des dotations
gel dès cette année et je vois sur le
terrain des projets qui sont arrêtés je
crois que tout cela
ceux qui voteraient pour les candidats
dans marche aux sénatoriales votre en
fin de compte pour dire que le
gouvernement continue ce sera un soutien
à cette politique défavorable aux
collectivités territoriales les élus
locaux sont raisonnables ils ne voteront
pas à mon avis en masse compte en faveur
d'une politique qui les menacent